今天想跟大家聊一個我覺得特別出乎意料的創新。我們常聽到AI跟機器人是未來的趨勢，但多數人可能會聯想到高端製造或智慧家居。
嗯，我猜啦，可能是那種很複雜的技術，離我們日常生活或中小企業比較遠的那種吧？像什麼機器人太空探測之類的。
其實不然。最近有一家叫做 Exclaim Robotics 的新創公司，他們剛獲得了 429 萬歐元的前期種子輪融資，但他們做的事情，你可能真的沒想到。
喔？是什麼？聽起來錢不少，應該是蠻有前景的題目。
他們要做的是「維護 AI 數據中心的機器人」。
維護數據中心？你是說，讓機器人去換個硬碟、擦擦灰塵這種事？這有什麼特別的？AI 數據中心不是應該都很高科技、很自動化了嗎？怎麼還會需要機器人去做這種勞務工作？
這就是有趣的地方了。CEO 兼創辦人 Helen Oleynikova 就提到，現在數據中心的創新速度，簡直像太空競賽，電力密度已經快要達到物理極限了。
尤其她說，未來下一代的 AI 數據中心，電力傳輸會直接在機架內部使用 800 伏特的直流電。
800 伏特？等等，這電壓也太高了吧？那一般維修人員去開機架，不是非常危險嗎？會不會有觸電風險？
對，這就是重點。她說，這麼高的電壓，打開機架都有電弧閃絡的風險。簡單的維護，像是換個故障的硬碟或是重新插拔光學收發器，都變得非常危險。
原來如此，所以這其實是把「高風險」的工作自動化了？這個點有意思，那他們具體怎麼做呢？是讓機器人直接取代人去操作嗎？
是的。他們打造的是「自主移動機器人」，能在數據中心內部進行例行性的維修和保養。Exclaim Robotics 提到，他們會先從高頻率的維修任務開始。
像是更換和清潔光纖模組、網路線，還有更換硬碟這些。這些都是需要重複做，但對人來說又有潛在危險的工作。
嗯，聽起來這個市場需求確實存在。但機器人維修這種精密的工作，精準度夠嗎？會不會搞砸了，反而造成更大損失？
Exclaim 的做法是，先在模擬環境中訓練機器人。讓機器人能比在真實硬體上練習更多次，直到它足夠可靠。
這樣聽起來成本應該不低吧？研發這麼一套系統，還有機器人的硬體設備，這錢要怎麼賺回來？
他們剛拿到 429 萬歐元的資金，主要是用來打造首批原型機、採購機器人硬體，還有擴大工程團隊。而且 Founderful 的 Antonia Albert 也說，現在 AI 數據中心擴張的速度太快，已經趕不上技術人員的供給了。
所以除了危險性，人力短缺也是一個原因？那對於一般的中小企業主來說，這個案例有什麼可以借鑑的嗎？我們可能沒有 AI 數據中心。
當然有。這個案例其實提醒我們，AI 和機器人技術不只是用在高大上的地方。你可以看看公司裡有哪些「重複性高」、「危險性高」或「單純很累人」的工作？
像是工廠的基礎設施檢查、店裡的夜間盤點，甚至是一些簡單的設備巡檢和保養。這些都能思考能不能導入自動化。
喔，我懂了。就像清潔機器人一樣，只是換了一個更高階一點的應用場景。那對一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶到日常工作中嗎？
我覺得可以換個角度。想想你工作中哪些是「機械性」的任務，或是需要「處理風險」的環節？
比如重複性的資料整理、文件歸檔，或是某些必須要謹慎小心的安全檢查。思考能不能用工具或系統來輔助，甚至讓它們部分自動化，把時間留給更有價值、更需要人腦判斷的工作。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候我們需要跳脫框架，重新檢視那些我們習以為常的「勞務」。